[Musique]
c'est assez gros pour être des boissons fraîches pour
le garçon d'anniversaire en
ce moment Kosta qu'est-ce que tu fais en train d'
appliquer Je veux ton cul aussi maman
qui parle comme ça je le fais ça marche penses-
y nos couilles ou où sont ses yeux ne
font pas  c'est mec tu es beaucoup trop rapide tais-
toi
[Applaudissements]
je suis Thomas kubs c'est mon anniversaire aujourd'hui
tu devrais certainement passer c'est sur
Dickens Street c'est ta fête que vous organisez
c'est ouais je
vais je dois être fou cool  à ce
soir les gars, alors qu'en pensez-vous de votre propre femme d'affaires?
j'ai reçu un autre appel
je suis sûr que les voisins exagèrent
il est temps de le fermer ça ne peut pas être
sérieux c'est une super fête on
va le fermer ou j'appelle les
flics j'appelle les flics  sur ton cul
maintenant fais-le
génie tout est sur bande tout ce que j'ai c'est que
tu frappes ce petit enfant '  s visage
que cherches-tu des préservatifs Je
travaille sur quelque chose en bas la seule
chose sur laquelle tu travailles est le diabète tu es
gros
nous aurons une journée entière pour réparer cet
endroit comme neuf qu'en est-il de cela et si mes
parents le voient  personne ne verra ça
pour nous, je le promets, alors vous savez cette
fête de lycée à Pasadena avez-vous vu
les images